well it finally happened not only did we
get a new admittedly short trailer for
the game formerly known as breath of the
wild 2 but we also got the name welcome
to the legend of zelda tears of the
kingdom there was a lot that they showed
in this minute and a half trailer so
let's get started breaking everything
down the first image that we see is one
of a new individual who i personally
believe is a new deity that we haven't
seen in previous games or at least one
that we haven't seen in person but more
on that later strangely this character
is shown with several inhuman features
starting with its ears which are rather
long the designs on the forehead and
neck are also very similar to the
architecture of the sky islands that
we've been teased with since the very
first trailer for the game heavily
implying and even confirming that
whoever this is is the leader of the
people group responsible for this
ancient architecture and these
hieroglyphic-like drawings the next shot
we're shown which is assumedly also on
the same wall as the mysterious
individual is that of a battle we can
see the familiar maulins and even
bokoblins which are shown to be sporting
their new longer horns battling against
a race of human-like people with
revealing symbols on their shields which
we have not seen before presumably these
people are none other than the
mysterious race which most people are
hoping will end up being the zonai and
there is some pretty good evidence for
it featured later in this trailer we
know that this battle is one from an age
gone by because we have no record of
this people group and whatever conflict
is happening here and because the
bokoblins's appearances are different
with horns that are different from what
they had in the first game because of
this shot right here i'm now decently
convinced that the hyrule we're seeing
with these long horned goblins is hyrule
in the distant past although i haven't
worked out a complete theory on that
just yet you'll also notice that these
moblins and bokoblins are walking within
spreading malice on the ground heavily
implying that these monsters that we've
been battling in breath of the wild are
in fact made of malice which is also
proven by the blood moon cutscene next
we are shown a wider shot of mysterious
individual that opened the trailer
surrounded by what appears to be
floating symbols that we commonly
associate with the zonai and some
unknown writing on the bottom left the
deity seems to be positioned atop a
floating island which makes sense given
all the other floating islands we see in
the sky as the shot pans up we can see
that there are seven of these stones and
as zelda fans know by heart seven is the
number of sages that were responsible
for sealing ganon away now we have to
wonder how exactly this ancient
civilization and this particular deity
are possibly connected to the sages of
legend the next shot is especially
mysterious it shows a girl with pointed
ears seemingly being either sacrificed
or otherwise lifted upward into the sky
with what looks to be malice underneath
the same individual is then shown
cupping hands with somebody else someone
whose hand is larger with bracelets
adorning the wrist if you'll recall
we've seen this hand before this is the
exact hand of the new deity complete
with the larger fingers and the bracelet
who could also be none other than the
green hand shown off in the very first
trailer above them just out of sight is
potentially two more of these symbolic
stones positioned together in a way that
mimics the sun it's also noteworthy that
this girl shown cupping hands here is
the same girl that was shown previously
levitating upward with the same pointed
ears long flowing hair and dress this
can only be assumed to be zelda but the
problem is the zelda that we know of
does not have longer hair anymore so
this is either a prophecy about our
zelda or it's a previous one maybe even
the first one but more on that later
immediately following this shot is one
of our familiar hero link sporting the
new shield shown in the previous trailer
opening a giant stone door into this sky
world or skyrule as i like to call it
this door is adorned with symbology as
well there is most notably the giant
circular twin dragon-like symbol
positioned front and center that also
appears once again at the end of the
trailer as the logo for the game on the
circle is more mysterious writing that
was shown previously on the wall most
intriguingly though is the eye symbol
that link touches in order to open the
door this could be representative of his
eyes opening to the new world or it
could as most fans know be a form of the
shika eye symbol which further
strengthens the theory that this ancient
race and the chica are connected also
it's notable that not only are the twin
dragons shown to be in a circular
pattern but this also seems to mimic the
cupping hands shown between zelda and
the deity implying that they are twins
once link opens the doors we are greeted
with the knowledge that he is already on
a sky island he then sprints forward
giving us a better view of the empty
shrine located directly in front of him
the camera then abruptly cuts to a
backward angle of link's sprinting but
it's clearly a different setting than
what we were just shown since the giant
doors he just opened are not visible and
the ground now features much more plant
life the camera swoops around link
showing off some structures located
behind him that features some sort of
buildings on top as well as a giant
cliff and another floating mini island
which has trees and some other
structures present once the camera shows
what's in front of link we then see more
sky islands and a particular giant
structure directly ahead off in the
distance this structure has a layered
design pattern that seems to call back
to the design of the mysterious deity
shown at first perhaps it is the temple
where this individual is located we are
shown many other sky islands in the
distance but it's presently impossible
to tell what's exactly going on with
each one of them so we'll move on for
now lincoln dives headfirst off the
island he was on showcasing once again
the highlight of the upcoming title
which is ascension and descension
between two worlds as link dives through
the clouds you can then dimly see the
familiar landscape of hyrule underneath
we are then shown link jumping onto and
clinging to a slab of rock within the
faron jungle region that appears to have
fallen down from skyrim which he then
uses his new powers to reverse through
time and return to its original position
using this to ascend this slab of rock
also appears to be associated with these
mysterious stone fragments in the water
on hyrule's surface also giving heavy
implications to the ancient race being
zonai which are the people responsible
for the stone fragments scattered
throughout the area the next shot is
back to link but as lots of fans are
speculating potentially another link
from another time it's very peculiar
that they still show this link with long
hair and rudimentary gear as opposed to
this link with the extremely familiar
and more modern hylian gear this
long-haired link is shown to be climbing
sky islands but everything is dark
implying that either this is night or
that this is somehow under the ground
also he's climbing up a root of a tree
implying that it was once under the
ground meaning that these sky islands
may not have always been in the sky the
next and final shot of the trailer is
also one of the most telling we see blue
link diving down to hyrule but this is
clearly hyrule after ganondorf has
already raised the castle which is
spewing a new deadly form of malice
that's also shown to be spewing out of
death mountain perhaps malice is now
corrupting lava as well as water like it
did in the first game as link falls we
can see more small islands scattered
around as well as a giant one in the
distance and we can also see more of the
ancient rune drawings also present
underneath hyrule castle link then
proceeds to land on an upgraded much
bigger glider that he can actually kneel
and ride on top of instead of hanging on
to the underside and we know that he'll
still be using a new version of the
classic glider from the previous trailer
so this seems to be a much more hardy
glider that he'll use simply to glide
more quickly in order to cover much more
ground since he'll be able to glide
anywhere in hyrule after jumping down
from sky rule link then appears to be
heading towards a mountain and the name
is escaping me currently but it's a
familiar one that now also has this
ancient runic drawing on it i'm not sure
if this means that these are the only
spots link will be able to land or if it
implies some sort of event happening at
these marked locations but either way
link is clearly heading towards it
lastly as link glides towards the marked
mountain we can see the familiar circle
dragon logo form out of the green
ancient energy as the logo fades in and
we're blatantly shown who zelda was
cupping hands with right behind the
words it is none other than the deity
that we saw at the first now this is the
end of the trailer but i have a theory
that i'd like to present before wrapping
up that has some very very very strong
implications of being true as we can see
there are many similarities between the
new deity and who i'm presuming is zelda
they both have long ears triangular
markings under the eyes circular
paddings that look like jewelry adorning
their bodies and they're heavily implied
to be symbolic of the twin dragons that
equal one another it could be that due
to this deity sporting long ears and the
ancient people serving it that this is
none other than the goddess hylia
herself and her original hylian race or
perhaps the original chica race or
perhaps a combination of both called the
zonai this added to the fact that this
deity's green energy can be used to
repair the master sword makes me think
that it must mean that we are returning
to the original hylia before the events
of skyward sword and that she will be
able to repair her sword her goddess
blade with her green energy and perhaps
that green link is the original hero and
perhaps hailey's tears for her kingdom
will finally be explained and the reason
why nintendo considered it a spoiler is
because we will finally know why the
sheikah symbol is an eye with a tear but
that's just a theory one that needs to
be fleshed out more but i'm pretty sure
is
more or less accurate what did you guys
think of the trailer are you happy with
the new name tears of the kingdom let me
know in the comments below i am beyond
stoked for this game and will likely be
covering it more so be sure to leave a
like on this video to spread it around
and subscribe if you haven't already to
stick around for so much more follow me
on my socials and that's all i've got
for this one this is bandit signing out
peace
[Music]